Frazier was one of the most successful
sitcoms of the last 30 years turning its
talented cast into pop culture icons now
Dr Crane and Company are going back on
the air here's what the cast has been up
to since the original series ended and
who's coming back for round two the
titular role of Dr Frazier crane the
scholarly psychiatrist and host of the
Dr Frazier crane show is played by
Kelsey Grammer his most iconic role to
date grammar played Frazier for a total
of 20 years including his time on Cheers
in a 2022 interview with Yahoo news when
discussing his upcoming reprisal of the
role which made him a household name
grammar described the character as quote
like putting on a favorite old jacket
since hanging up that up title jacket
grammar has worked prolifically in
Hollywood as both an actor and producer
immediately following the end of Frasier
grammar played Mr skibness in the Tenny
Fairchild film The Good Humor man in
2008 he starred as President Andrew
Boone in the comedic political drama
swing votes alongside Kevin Costner and
he also appeared as himself in a handful
of episodes on the NBC comedy 30 Rock
one rule anybody gets hurt during the
score we leave him behind to die now
who are you and what are we doing
grammar would also dip his toe into the
Blockbuster Waters in 2006 starring as
beast and X-Men the Last Stand returning
to the franchise in an uncredited Cameo
and X-Men Days of Future Past and
playing Harold adinger in Transformers
Age of Extinction Grammer also continues
to provide the voice for Sideshow Bob
and The Simpsons which he first began in
1990. he has several projects in
production or development besides the
new Frazier with his latest project as
of this video including a role in the
historical religious drama Jesus
Revolution
it might surprise fans that Martin
Frazier's live-in caretaker Daphne Moon
to learn that British actress Jane
leaves almost didn't land the role
according to Showbiz cheat sheet the
production team had originally sought
out Rosie Perez for the role looking
back on leaves's 263 episodes now it
seems ridiculous to think that anybody
else was ever considered for the role of
Daphne a performance that earned her an
Emmy nomination in 1993. after Frasier
came to an end in 2004 leaves took a
two-year break from acting before
returning to provide the voice of ini
and Garfield A Tale of Two Kitties she
works regularly in television for
several years appearing in shows like
misconceptions and Desperate Housewives
and doing voice over work for the
animated children's show Phineas and
Ferb in 2010 Leafs landed the role of
Joyce scrogs in the TV Land sitcom Hot
in Cleveland when she played for Five
Seasons leaves also starred as kit boss
in the medical drama of the resident
which concluded his sixth season in
January 2023 before being canceled
months later
in 2021 levs told the independent that
she wouldn't leave the show to join the
Frasier Revival but now that the show is
over maybe she found the time to join in
Frazier's cold-hearted younger brother
Dr Niles crane is played by David Hyde
Pierce
he won four Emmys for his performance
only one fewer than grammar and was an
integral part of the show's main cast
unfortunately for fans of Niles Yahoo
news reported that the actor wasn't
interested in reprising his role in the
upcoming reboot after Fraser Hyde Pierce
worked regularly in theater he played
sir Robin in the Monty Python musical
spanalots from 2005 to 2006 and was
nominated for a Tony Award for his
performance as Horace Van Der gelder in
the 2017 Revival of Hello Dolly Hyde
Pierce has also continued to work in
film and television in 2010 he starred
in the comedic crime Thriller the
perfect host and in 2017 he reprized his
role as Professor Henry Newman in the TV
miniseries Wet Hot American Summer first
day of camp he also played Frank pratty
in season six of The Good Wife and lent
his voice to an episode of Sesame Street
as well as voicing Cecil the brother of
grammar's Sideshow Bob in three episodes
of The Simpsons but you'll find one gets
more respect as a humble civil servant
than as a homicidal maniac or a Clown's
sidekick Hyde Pierce returned to
television in 2022 to play Julia Child's
husband Paul in the HBO Max series Julia
is also set to Star as father Conor in
the upcoming horror film The Georgetown
project which is slated for release
sometime in 2023
the producer of Frasier's radio show Ros
Doyle is played by Perry Gilpin
encouraged by her parents to pursue her
passion for acting since she was a child
growing up in Dallas Gilpin studied
acting at the University of Texas and
the British American dramatic Academy in
London according to Ability magazine she
performed on stage in New York before
relocating to Los Angeles and Landing
her big break on Frazier Gilpin is still
working regularly on television
following the end of Frazier Gilpin
popped up on shows like medium Desperate
Housewives and Law and Order Criminal
Intent and lends her vocal talents to
the animated comedy King Of The Hill in
2011 Gulpin had an on-screen reunion
with a Frasier co-star Jane leaves in an
episode of Hot in Cleveland arguably her
biggest TV role since Frazier was as Kim
Keeler in the ABC Sports drama Make It
or Break It which ran for Four Seasons
Gilpin also appeared in a 2017 episode
of Broad City in later years gopin has
been working more on the big screen with
smaller roles in movies like occupy
Texas flock of dudes and the Outdoorsman
recent roles include the romantic comedy
we broke up playing Mrs Donahue and
rushed and Sarah Hughes in the
historical drama the anthrax attacks
according to deadline she's back on
board for the Frasier Revival in a
recurring role the role of Martin the
crane Brothers retired cop father was
played by the late John Mahoney for his
performance Mahoney was nominated for
two Primetime Emmys in 1999 in 2003.
Mahoney's long career began in 1981 and
spanned nearly four decades before he
passed away in 2018 at 77. despite his
success in Hollywood he seemed to prefer
living in Chicago and performing on the
stage I just want to be back home and I
want to be on stage and where I enjoy it
after his role in Frazier Mahoney
provided the voice of happy and Kronk's
New Groove and appeared in a 2006
episode of ER in 2007 he landed a major
film role as poppy in the Steve Carell
romantic comedy Dan in Real Life and
lent his voice to a season 19 episode of
The Simpsons the following year Mahoney
appeared in the first season of in
treatment and featured in two episodes
of the USA action drama Burn Notice in
2011 he joined the cast of the Fraser
cast magnet on in Cleveland in his final
performance before his passing was in a
2015 episode of Foyle's War
Martin's lovable Canine Companion Eddie
was played by an adorable four-legged
thespian by the name of moose he's
appeared in most episodes besides the
five members of the main cast a total of
163 episodes across 10 seasons Frazier
is often at odds with Eddie taking
umbrage with his propensity to stare
picturedly at him for prolonged periods
of time
I said dumb
good boy Eddie just get down good good
good good good Eddie get down get down
during his distinguished 10-year career
this demean YouTube Jack Russell Terrier
logged four acting credits Frazier was
his first small screen debut but after
his first season on the air he
immediately booked a job in an episode
of the five Mrs buchanans as Petey the
following year he played Monty in an
episode of The Comedy High Society in
2000 moose made the jump to Hollywood
staring as the titular dog in the film
My Dog Skip which also featured a
performance by his son Enzo Frazier was
Moose's last on-screen performance
before he passed away in 2006 at the
ripe old age of 112 in dog years
Frazier isn't the only colorful
personality at Seattle's kacl radio
station following the psychiatrist time
slots is the Gonzo Sports show and its
host the Macho womanizing Bob Bulldog
Brisco played by Dan Butler Butler
popped up in 53 episodes of Frasier
beginning in its first season and it
wasn't immediately clear if he's coming
back for the Revival after his final
appearance in 2004 Butler stayed active
in the television industry continuing to
lend his voice to Hey Arnold on
Nickelodeon as several characters
including Mr Simmons and appearing in
episodes of quintuplets and Dr Vegas
he's popped up on several popular shows
since then including one episode roles
and Malcolm in the Middle Supernatural
house and monk in 2011 he returned to
the big screen appearing as Steve
Carell's boss in the romantic comedy
Crazy Stupid Love in 2020 Butler played
Dr Alan Mendelson in the romantic drama
all my life and in 2022 he was featured
in the Marilyn Monroe biopic blonde
another kacl personality restaurant
critic Gil Chesterton is a recurring
character throughout the show's 11th
season run he's played by Royal Academy
of dramatic arts Alum Edward Hibbert he
appeared in a total of 29 episodes
including an appearance in the series
finale in 2004. ibrid has worked
steadily since the end of Frazier enter
the series concluded he played sir
Michael Strickland in the Romantic
Thriller at different loyalty in 2006 he
was featured in the Christopher Nolan
Thriller The Prestige and appeared as
Randall Farber in an episode of Gilmore
Girls much like several of his Frasier
co-stars he also appeared in an episode
of hot Cleveland in 2014. in 2018
Hibbert provided the voice of a talking
parrot umbrella and Mary Poppins returns
and was featured in episodes of Grace
and Frankie and blue bloods in 2019.
kacl's technical assistant Noel shimsky
is played by television journeyman
Patrick Kerr first introduced in season
one kurwitz star in a total of 22
Episodes over the 11 Seasons I have a
secret weapon
I can faint at will check it out
after Fraser Kerr appeared in an episode
of the much less successful sitcom
spin-off series Joey he followed that up
with a small role in the 2005 action
biopic Domino as a DMV manager and the
following year appeared in an episode of
the CBS sitcom The New Adventures of Old
Christine over the next decade he had
several one episode roles in shows such
as CSI Jesse Elementary and Hannah
Montana later film roles included the
2014 comedy friends and Romans in 2015's
anesthesia sensang Curry has worked in
short films and on episodes of Little
America on Apple TV plus and the HBO Max
crime comedy search party in 2023 he
appeared as a main cast member in
another Apple TV plus original the big
door prize first appearing in season 5
kacl station manager Kenny Daly is
played by Tom McGowan he worked
primarily in film before appearing in
Frazier beginning in 1992 the role in
Michael Mann's historical drama The Last
of the Mohicans it had some experience
in the sitcom World playing Bernie and
Everybody Loves Raymond following
Frazier McGowan stayed busy into 2004 he
had a lead role in the romantic comedy
doggone love since then he stayed in the
world of Television featuring shows such
as Hannah Montana Boston Legal and CSI
unsurprisingly he also wound up in a
2011 episode of Hot in Cleveland and the
following year he showed up in an
episode of Modern Family in 2015 McGowan
played Congressman Moyes in an episode
of the HBO political comedy beat and
returned to the big screen to play a
role in freeheld alongside Julianne
Moore and Michael Shannon two years
later he had a supporting role as Jax
riddle in season one of the good fight
his most recent role was in 2022 when
McGowan appeared in an episode of the
NBC comedy American Auto
Daphne Moon's overbearing mother
Gertrude who first appears in season 7
is portrayed by veteran actress
Millicent Martin's career began in
British television all the way back in
1957 and she would make appearances
throughout the remainder of the show
with her final appearance coming in
season 11. after her final appearance in
Frasier Martin popped up in a 2004
episode of The Drew Carey Show and
appeared in Will and Grace the following
year her television career has been
going strong since then and she has
acted in episodes of Chuck Castle bones
and Modern Family not wanting to miss
out on the Frasier cast's favorite
Studio Lot hangout spot she appeared in
two episodes of Hot in Cleveland and
appeared in a small role in the 2017
movie The Last Word in 2017 McGowan took
on the role of Joan Margaret in the
Netflix original comedy series Grace and
Frankie first appearing in season 3 and
playing the character in 20 episodes to
the show's seventh and final season in